fue en el minuto 92 un país entero se
unió en un grito de gol el más fuerte de
la historia según algunos
con el tanto de fred y ring con la
selección colombia pasa a octavos de
final del mundial del 90 al empatar con
alemania el favorito
es el momento que muchos recuerdan al
conmemorar el fallecimiento del coloso
como lo llamaban con cariño nació en
buenaventura y su talento con el balón
lo llevó a bogotá la capital donde se
vistió de rojo al debutar con
independiente santafé
su potencia habilidad y lectura del
juego lo convirtieron en un volante como
pocos y lo conducirían a portar la
camiseta de otro equipo colombiano el
américa de cali y el brasileño palmeiras
su calidad traspasó fronteras y los
llevó a europa primero al nápoles y
luego al real madrid pero sin duda la
cima su carrera la encontró de regreso a
latinoamérica donde se convirtió en uno
de los ídolos del equipo brasileño
corinthians portando la banda de capitán
y la batuta del juego el club consiguió
su primer trofeo del mundial de clubes
rincón brillo en la época de oro de la
selección colombia anotó 17 goles dos de
ellos especialmente recordados en el
histórico 05 contra argentina en el 93
asistió a la cita mundialista en tres
ocasiones compartiendo el campo de juego
con otras figuras del balompié
colombiano rené higuita faustino
asprilla carlos 'el pibe' valderrama y
andrés escobar su vida fuera de las
canchas no estuvo exenta de polémica fue
buscado por la interpol al ser acusado
por tener nexos con el narcotráfico en
2013 tuvo un accidente automovilístico
nueve años después otro siniestro vial
se cobra la vida del coloso del fútbol
colombiano